Good evening
I'm Brian Greene
In April 1919
a 34-year-old German Mathematician
was in his study
sitting on his desk
His 9 year old son was on the couch
were often being with daddy's working
and
Theodor Kaluza was there at his desk
doing calculation as he often would
when all the sudden
he opened his eyes wide
he slammed the desk with his hands
he shot to his feet
and he began to sing an Aria from Figaro
The program here tonight
will explore what was the Theodor Kaluza
was singing about
he had found the possibility
that there is reason to believe that our universe might have
more than the three dimensions
that everyday space that we all know about
the problem that will be the discussion tonight
will follow the variations on that theme
that have rippled through physics
over the last eight decades
and we' ll discuss where our thinking is today on this possibility
of more dimensions than meet the eye
now, to give you a sense of where this idea came from
Calabi-Yau